bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour clichés
or not clichés l'émission qui examine
les clichés qui servent à combattre les
clichés en biologie évolutive
aujourd'hui on va vous parler de la
notion de chaînon manquant vous nous
l'avez demandé
la voici mise en situation regarde là
bas ce magnifique ornithorynque c'est un
chaînon manquant entre le reptile de
mammifères du tout voyons c'est un
intermédiaire structurale on est des
scientifiques on n'est pas des
scientifiques un fou quand elle être un
peu précis dans les terrains du parc
scientifique battait pas un scientifique
on dit intermédiaire structurale une
fois n'est pas coutume commençons déjà
par ce qui marche bien avec la notion de
chaînon manquant parce que la notion de
chaînon manquant déjà c'est une notion
qui est très populaire
donc c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a
forcément besoin d'expliquer tout le
monde a une image mentale de ce qu'est
un chaînon manquant mail avantages du
chaînon manquant c'est que c'est une
notion profondément évolutionniste vous
ne pouvez pas parler de chaînon manquant
sans parler d'évolution donc c'est
quelque chose qui ne peut pas être
corrompue par un créationniste un
chaînon manquant ça veut dire qu'
évidemment c'est un intermédiaire entre
deux autres trucs exactement donc il ya
forcément une évolution évolution donc
par exemple si vous prenez le fossile
vivant c'est très populaire c'est une
notion de biologie évolutive aussi mais
c'est très très facile a détourné de son
but originel qui est juste de décrire
une espèce qui évolue peu à la basse
alors que le chaînon manquant
il n'y a pas d'erreur c'est forcément
évolution donc rejeté la notion de
chaînon manquant c'est un petit peu jeté
le bébé avec l'eau du bain juste pour
éviter juste pour éviter une
interprétation relativement linéaire de
l'évolution interprétation linéaire qui
comme on l'a dit dans une précédente
vidéo n'est pas si fausse que ça d'un
certain point de vue maintenant
examinons le concept d'intermédiaires
structurale alors déjà intermédiaire
structurale ouais c'est jargonneux à
souhait mais c'est bien pour le scrabble
ah ouais ça compte triple au scrabble
c'est parfait donc intermédiaire
structurale si vous voulez vous garantir
de perdre votre auditoire ce mot c'est
le mot c'est ce que vous cherchez donc
voilà c'est du gros mots scientifiques
qui contrairement au chaînon manquant
n'a vraiment aucune résonance populaire
et puis en plus le concept
d'intermédiaires structurelles c'est un
truc qui est complètement
interchangeables avec chaînon manquant
pour qu'on utilise de la même manière au
final oui la plupart des gens qui
utilisent le mot intermédiaire
structurale de toute façon l'utilisent
de façon complètement synonyme en fait
avec chaînon manquant donc finalement à
quoi bon c'est pas bon esquiver le mot
chaînon manquant
c'est un peu comme si on faisait de la
politique et qu'on essayait juste de
remplacer un mot par un autre exactement
c'est ça j'ai encore du politiquement
correct
et enfin il ya le fait que dans
intermédiaire structurale ya
intermédiaires et intermedia bas c'est
pareil que chez nombre encore au final
saluerait dire que c'est entre d'autres
clubs on trace une ligne il ya
l'intermédiaire au mieux encore on veut
éviter le terme de chaînon manquant à
cause de la ligne linéarité sous jacente
du terme mais au final la notion
d'intermédiaires structurale contient le
mot intermédiaires qui renvoie aussi à
cette notion de linéarité quoi donc
finalement et b c'est pareil hein c'est
kif kif
en conclusion le chaînon manquant est ce
que ces linéaires et oui oui mais ce
qu'il faut s'en passer pour autant et
ben nous nous parce que sinon on se
priverait d'un élément de poids contre
le créationnisme et d'un élément surtout
qui est très populaire
exactement voilà c'est tout pour le
chaînon manquant vous remercie d'avoir
suivi notre émission et on vous dis à
très bientôt sur la prochaine